snap true reality introduces the
automatic alignment of virtual objects
to physical constraints by calculating
those constraints from the real world in
real time
positioning virtual content and space
around a user is an important task in
many augmented reality applications
while it is possible to do so without
regard to the real world surrounding the
user many augmented reality experiences
tend to require a tight alignment
between the virtual and real environment
controlling the six degrees of freedom
to position and orient content so that
it is precisely aligned with the real
world can be quite a challenging task
that might otherwise be very easy with
snapping in this work we present a
proof-of-concept system that allows one
to use the physical geometry around them
to easily position virtual objects in
their environment our prototype uses a
Microsoft Kinect sensor Lumis optical
see-through glasses and an optic track
system to maintain the relative pose
between the user and the Kinect our
system specifically focuses on
extracting physical edges and planar
surfaces as we believe they represent a
rich set of constraints common to many
environments edges and surfaces are
extracted by analyzing the color depth
and surface normals of the environment
as the environment dynamically evolves
the definition of the constraints may
change to represent the new geometry we
take special care to minimize any
temporal noise and allow using
constraints that change smoothly over
time we can detect a variety of physical
constraints in many different
environments that can be used for
guiding the position and modification of
virtual objects please see our paper for
a detailed description of our algorithm
to further investigate snapping an
augmented reality we conducted to user
experiments in the first experiment
participants position and skilled
augmented reality app windows to specify
targets with and without snapping if the
app window is not close enough to the
target we notify the user to try again
participants positioned virtual contents
significantly faster with snapping than
without participants also indicated that
they felt more fatigued while not using
snapping than with using snapping this
is indicated by observing the difference
in physical movement by the participants
under both conditions in the second
experiment participants created virtual
3d objects guided by constraints
extracted from the physical environment
a 3d box lying on the surface parallel
to edges and walls and the desired
dimensions could be constructed in
seconds easy in Scituate enabled
participants to be quite creative such
as creating virtual shelves extruding
cubes to Heights of dynamic scene
elements or using a physical measuring
tape to guide high extrusions in summary
snap to reality online meant techniques
help users align virtual content to
real-world constraints please see our
paper for more details including an
analysis of design considerations for
future snap to reality systems
you